i don't trust anybody including you i
love you but you know there's not a lot
of people i trust i wish you'd abided by
that rule before you pulled all american
soldiers out of kabul a majority of
americans no longer consider you to be
competent focused or effective in the
job i haven't seen that poll
oh boy
so here is joe biden being even less
competent than usual over the weekend
uh he he got he always gets very testy
if you ask him like a tough question
about the fact that he just you know
blew up america's foreign policy like
completely blew it up because china is
ecstatic today
right we just lost every base we have in
the region it's not just that we've lost
bases in afghanistan lost our bases in
in pakistan
we have no surrounding bases our nearest
space is now in qatar
which is hundreds of miles away
we have no over the horizon capacity we
lost all of our intelligence sources on
the ground who are likely to be murdered
by the taliban
china is ecstatic because now they have
land access
they now have a basically a bridge all
the way from china through afghanistan
into iran
to syria to to lebanon like this is all
chinese allied territory now you got the
russians who are doing the same thing
and it's it's a full-scale geopolitical
disaster and if you're an american ally
you're looking at the biden
administration going i don't trust you
i'm gonna have to triangulate now i'm
gonna have to look to russia and china
try to cut a few deals try to shore up
you know kind of
backfill some sort of national security
here
i've never seen anything remotely like
it and the president of the united
states is not with us there's nothing
going on upstairs the lights are on but
nobody is home and frankly the lights
are dimming very very quickly
here's the president of the united
states getting to test you and ask
questions about it
i don't trust anybody including you i
love you but you know there's not a lot
of people i trust okay he was asked if
he trusts the taliban now and the reason
he was asked that is because he is
trusting the taliban to allow americans
out
and the reporter says do you trust him
he said i don't trust you man i don't
trust anybody trust no one well i wish
you'd abided by that rule before you
pulled all american soldiers out of
kabul preventing us from getting our
people out
if you didn't trust them why did you do
this this was unnecessary this wasn't
the taliban defeated the united states
military in armed combat this was not
even the unit the f the taliban defeated
the afghan military in armed combat this
was the united states withdrew close air
support from the afghan military
withdrew all american military
contractors allowing the afghan air
force to fly this is the united states
completely destroyed the basis for the
afghan army and the afghan army
disappeared
the taliban didn't take kabul in ground
assault fighting they didn't take kabul
in hand-to-hand combat they took kabul
without firing a shot they took kandahar
without firing a shot they took missouri
sharif without firing a shot that's
because of biden no one else just biden
that's all
it's unreal
now what's hilarious is that he says
like these two clips back to back so he
says i don't trust anybody including you
i don't trust the taliban but he's going
to urge the taliban to respect the
well-beings of afghans oh i'm sure
that's what's going to happen mr
president i'm sure that's what's going
to happen now that you've pulled out all
protective forces and destroyed all of
our allies and left anyone who allied
with us at the risk of being shot in the
face by the taliban
i am sure that the taliban are thinking
to themselves how can we protect the
well-being of afghans in coordination
with the desires of the biden
administration that just gave us a
apache attack helicopters
the what
what the
what in the actual
there's no way to do the show without
the f word there's just no way
here is here's the president of the
united states
the taliban has a
taliban has to make a fundamental
decision is a taliban going to attempt
to
be able to unite and provide for
the well-being of the people of
afghanistan which no one group has ever
done
since before feeling for hundreds of
years
and if it does it's going to need
everything from additional help in terms
of
economic assistance trade and a whole
range of things the taliban is going to
have many the taliban is going to have
to make a decision okay so let's say
they have to make a decision who knows
what decision they're going to make on
the one hand they could do all the
things joe biden wants them to do
on the other hand they could tell him to
go screw himself
kill everyone who allied with us stuff
the women back into burqas and then back
into the basement and then rape them
and do whatever the hell they want i
wonder which one i haven't
my hands up here i i think i know the
answer i think
it's a hard question i think i know the
answer to this one that's what the
taliban is going to do
i think i know this is really rough by
the way joe biden was then asked a
question about isis which again is
rising in afghanistan and here was joe
biden's electrifying response
in case you can't see that that's the
president of the united states walking
and doddering out the back door i kid
you not
it's the president of the united states
turning around and walking out the back
door
yeah man this is gonna go
fantastically well the good news is that
if joe biden should uh should actually
be declared incompetent which may in
fact have to happen at some point here
uh then uh the person who replaced him
kamala hair she's up for the job right
oh wait we have we have video of kamala
harris too
what an administration this is but no
bad tweets no bad tweets well you might
be asking yourself uh whether joe biden
is competent and the answer of course
is not he's not i mean joe biden is
literally just forgetting things now
he in this same presser he literally
forgot the name of his fema
administrator
which
i understand is a forgettable thing but
not if you're president and it's your
administrator i know the names of my
producers takes me a little while but
once i know him i know him here's the
president of the united states just
forget by the way he's there's a
teleprompter in front of him he's
speaking from teleprompter at this point
i can't uh think of anyone better to
lead this operation than
than uh
dan
chris well of
fema
um she's she before she headed up fema
she led the emergency response in new
york city i can't think of anyone better
to lead this effort than shabbat exams
again judean
yeah man okay well the good news is
waiting in the wings we have kamala
harris the most competent person she is
so confident so competent she's deeply
ready for this job she is so ready for
this job she'll be ready day one
i mean she might not need to be ready
day one but like we're maybe what 150
days into this administration so by day
200 you might need to be ready here is
kamala harris cackling like a crazy
person uh when when uh asked about
afghanistan which is always heartening
it's always great when the vice
president of the united states who by
the way
i don't know who books her travel
schedule you know she's headed to
vietnam today
like she's flying to vietnam
optics gang optics there's it's complete
what's your response to reports of
americans
i want to talk about two things first
afghanistan
we couldn't have a higher priority right
now and in particular i priority is
making sure that we safely evacuate
american citizens man is that a weird
tick is that a weird tick or what
madam vice president what about
afghanistan well let's let's take a
break here for that
what is that but the good news is she's
not the only one laughing
a lot of people laughing these days joe
biden is laughing it up so there's a
brand new poll
and shows that americans think he's
doing an unbelievably crappy job on
afghanistan the new poll which is uh
from
nbc news or cbs news rather cbs news
ugov
according to americans there's a poll
from three days ago
removal of u.s troops from afghanistan
has gone very badly 44
somewhat badly 30 percent somewhat well
very well five percent so the five
percent is ron klein and the taliban
meanwhile 74 of americans think this is
either gone very badly or somewhat badly
and the 21 who say somewhat well are
actually in the pay of the democratic
party presumably so joe biden was asked
about this it is hilarious to joe biden
the new poll out today shows americans
wanted to withdraw from afghanistan
but they disapprove of the way you've
handled it paul also found it based in
part in what's transpired in the last
week a majority of americans and forgive
me i'm just the messenger no longer
consider you to be competent focused or
effective in the job i haven't seen that
poll
it's out there um from cbs this morning
um what would you say
so uh remember that time that donald
trump would just deny polls remember
there would be people who would read him
poll numbers he'd just be like fake news
fake paw not real and everybody in the
middle go how dare he it's a real pole
but he's just not going to believe poles
now
so you read joe biden a poll saying that
most americans think that he's not
competent and jordan's like ah
and then he breaks out the caesar romero
honestly i've never seen a vice
president and a president who both
resembled the joker bizarrely it's it's
a it's a weird it's a weird thing it's
very very odd
but it's all fine probably it's all fine
he's uh he everything is solid
it's going well
we're being told by this administration
that that the competence is um is at
record high levels they are laser
focused on what they need to do here
oh boy
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment